hey guys it's just date and I am so
excited because my first app is in the
App Store and it is an app to teach you
guys to edit so I put a link in the
description where you guys can check it
out I worked with ripple training on
this and they are like the leader in
creating training courses specifically
in final cut so I'm so excited to show
this you if you guys do get the app make
sure you read it five stars and leave it
a nice review so more people can find it
in the App Store I have been editing for
such a long time like since 2005 this is
one of my first youtube videos I know
it's weird I actually shot this because
I needed some footage to teach myself
how to edit you can see that I'm on
Final Cut on my macbook but I'm also
using avid in the computer behind me
when it's like why are we using avid
edit the things that we're doing so I
took it upon myself trap myself Final
Cut and one of the best parts about this
training course is I actually give you
guys all of my footage so all of the
footage that I use to create this actual
YouTube video you guys have it and you
can edit right along with me it's also
really great because this app works in
Final Cut so there's a final cut
extension so basically you could be
editing in Final Cut with the footage
that I've supplied you and never
actually leave final cut so ripple
training and I have partnered together
and we made this really fun tutorial of
what I do from start to finish now
here's a quick preview of what we
created now drag to the right and you'll
get visual feedback on the right side of
the viewer to see exactly where that
clip will start there's also some
transitions and I'm gonna tell you right
now that my favorite transition is bloom
and I overuse it way too much but I love
it so let's take this little section and
click right at the edge and drag it this
action speeds up the center portion of
the clip now you've added the presets in
the viewer window is available so on the
left side you can see what it's like
before and the right side is what it
looks like after the compression is
added one of the things that I
personally learned while working on this
was using multicam clips I used them
previous
but I had never used them consistently
and for me I'm always shooting with two
camera setups so this was something that
I worked on really hard to make sure
that we included in this project because
now editing in multicam clips in Final
Cut is so easy so if you are shooting
with multiple cameras and separate audio
this is honestly something that everyone
shouldn't be using I am so excited for
you guys to check this out especially if
you are new to editing or if you have
been editing for a while I promise you
there will be something in it that you
learn you guys enjoy the app make sure
you guys leave it five stars and also
leave it a nice review that way more
people can find it in the Mac App Store
I was so excited I opened up my computer
and I was like its featured on the app
store I couldn't believe it it was like
a dream come true so thank you guys so
much for letting me live my dream and
create content with you and now let me
give back to you and let me teach you my
ways on a huge thank you to ripple
training for working on this with me
because we went every step of the way
they helped me create the courses they
basically like watched me edit a video
and then we took that and broke it down
into what would be the lessons how are
we gonna make this into something so a
huge thank you to them they also have a
bunch of other really great courses too
so I knew going into this that us
creating this together it was gonna be
awesome so once you guys have completed
my course go check out some other other
ones because honestly if you are looking
to learn final cut they do it in such a
way that it is so natural and I love the
final cut extension I mean you can
basically be editing along in Final Cut
you guys have any questions feel free to
tweet me I will also be in the comments
below so I hope that you guys enjoyed
this and I hope that you learn to edit
and of course feel free to share your
creations with me I look forward to
seeing what you guys make and that's it
happy editing
[Music]